nous allons nous intéresser à
l'initiative de l'association fly and
Kiss à présent association composée de
bénévoles par ailleurs pilote privé
bonsoir Alice l'objectif de cette
association fly and Kiss c'est de
permettre aux enfants de s'évader et
d'oublier pendant un temps leurs
problèmes leurs difficultés voir leurs
handicap aussi oui tout à fait ce sont
des enfants en difficulté ou des des
enfants en situation de handicap qui
sont amenés ou bien par le Secours
populaire ou bien par une association
hein de Montini pour des enfants sourds
ou bien encore des enfants du service
pédiatrique de l'hôpital Mignot à
Versailles fly and key s organisé par
exemple le 27 octobre dernier la 3e
édition des baptêms de l'air pour une
trentaine d'enfants cé à l'aérodrome de
saint-sire l'école avec nous Christophe
Teré et Ludovique bégeot bonsoir à vous
deux bonsoir vous êtes membrre de cette
association vous êtes aussi pilote privé
nous allons voir un petit peu en détail
he les actions de cette association et
puis avec vous Ludovic Béjot nous
reviendrons sur aviation et Handicap he
parce que vous êtes vous-même handicapé
alors tout d'abord cette association
comment une telle mobilisation est née
alors c'est un petit peu par par
accident en fait c'est c'est né à
l'occasion d'un Paris un soir un soir un
peu trop arrosé et donc on a démarré en
se disant tiens qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait
bien faire de nos vies maintenant qu'on
a passé la quarantaine et on a décidé de
fonder une association pour venir en
aide au défavorisés et d'en de profiter
pour allier ceci à notre passion pour
l'aéronautique et vous le regrettez pas
aujourd'hui paren général le lendemain
matin on
regrette regr que j'ai V la soirée le
soir mais non non le lendemain on était
on était très conscient de ce qu'on de
ce qu'on voulait faire et on est très
fier de ce qu'on a pu réaliser jusqu'à
maintenant est-ce que ce sont des
initiatifes qu'on retrouve dans d'autres
aérodromes dans les Yvelines les autres
aérodromes les plus connus sont Toussus
par exemple et les Mureau est-ce que
aussi dans ces aérodromes il y a de tels
initiativ
oui absolument il y a des initiatives
dans ces aérodromes là et partout
ailleurs en France c'est vrai que les
Mureau sont assez actifs aussi en terme
de d'accueil des personnes handicapées
parce que c'est l'un des six aéroclubs
équipés pour pass handicapé en France
euh donc effectivement on est très
sensible au sujet et on accueille très
régulièrement des baptêmes de l'air pour
différents types de handicap mentaux ou
physique quelles sont les réactions des
enfants est-ce qu'il y a des peurs la
joie on espère ils ont souvent peur de
Ludo en fait mais non plus sérieusement
ils sont les enfants ont ce merveilleux
qu'ils expriment très facilement leurs
émotions et donc en fait il y a trois
phases il y a une phase d'impatience
quand ils arrivent quand on les
accueille comme on voit effectivement
sur c'est sur les images euh il y a la
phase d'anxiété au moment de monter dans
l'avion et puis après il y a le
contraste saisissant avec le moment où
ils sortent de l'avion ils descendent de
l'avion et là on a un grand sourire il
sourit avec tout ils sourit avec leurs
bouches sourit avec leurs yeux et c'est
et c'est vraiment sympathique à voir il
faut que ce soit mémorable pour eux vous
voulez leur faire oublier leurs
difficultés c'est ça absolument
absolument et on y arrive l'espace du
vol et on on arrive à poursuivre ça
d'ailleurs avant et après le vol puisque
y on a on organise d'autres ateliers
focalisés autour de l'aviation quand on
les accueille hm hm comme des
constructions d'avion et cetera puis
aussi des des goûtés euh il y a une
dizaine de de de bénévoles he qui
étaient présents en tout cas samedi
est-ce qu'ils sont tous pilote est-ce
qu'il faut être pilote pour faire partie
de cette association c'est mieux oui
mais c'est ouvert on n'est pas on n'est
pas secctur on ouvre à tout le monde qui
veut venir jouer avec nous et donner du
du soleil et du plaisir aux enfants
alors on en vient maintenant au pilotage
proprement parler vous êtes pilote privé
tous les deux qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
ça veut dire que vous ne pouvez voler
que sur certains types d'avion dans une
certaine zone géographique ça veut dire
que en fait on vole pour son plaisir on
ne peut pas en faire une activité
commerciale donc on peut pas se faire
payer pour emmener des gens euh par
contre on peut partager les frais par
exemple au cours d'un vol mais
effectivement la la vocation de pilote
privé reste focalisé autour du loisir
même si l'activité est extrêmement
encadrée et de la même manière qu'un
avion privé vole comme un gros avion de
ligne c'est les mêmes principes de vol
qui régissent cette activité euh la
réglementation l'apprentissage suis des
règles très très stricte et très
draconienne donc c'est un loisir pour
les gens qui qui ont quand même envie de
d'une rigueur et d'être capable
effectivement d'appliquer notamment des
règles de sécurité qui sont extrêmement
importantes h alors vous Ludi beéjot
vous êtes handicapé est-ce que il a
fallu trouver un arrangement des adapter
les avions que vous pilotez alors c'est
une bonne question moi j'ai un handicap
qui ne m'empêche pas de vivre comme la
plupart des personnes handicapées
d'ailleurs j'ai toujours refusé dans
toute ma vie que ça soit pour l'aviation
ou d'autres domaines d'adapter mon
environnement à mon handicap c'est moi
qui m'adapte à l'environnement mais ça
c'est ma théorie malheureusement pour
d'autres personnes il y a des
adaptations qui existent pour les
personnes handicapées moteur
paraplégique on a inventé un système qui
s'appelle le malonniier qui remplace le
palonniier qui permet de diriger le
l'avion au sol et de coordonner les
virages une fois qu'on est en l'air pour
les personnes sourdes il y a le Sound
flyer qui est un pour pardon les
personnes déficientes visuel le sunflyer
qui est un système auditif qui permet de
donner par des sons dans les dans le
casque la position relative de l'avion
dans l'espace et pour les personnes
sourdes ell vole il y a des pilotes
sours en France il y a un pilote sour en
France il volent sur des espaces où la
radio n'est pas indispensable on va voir
justement comment ça se passe pour une
pilote une pilote en situation de de
sourdité justement mais juste à propos
de de votre façon de de piloter vous
vous n'avez pas du tout adapté votre
avion alors je n'ai pas adopté mon avion
enfin l'avion sur lequel je vole par
contre la DGAC imposé de voler sur un
type d'avion pour l'instant il voulait
me mettre un petit peu à l'épreuve et
voir si tout se passait bien là ça fait
4 ans que j'ai mon brevet et là je suis
en train de revenir vers la Djac pour
proposer d'autres types d'avion auquel
je pourrais éventuellement
prétendreavoir accès d' alors vous dites
il faut que je m'adapte moi à
l'environnement c'était difficile
justement de de prendre les le contact
avec avec cet avion et de pouvoir
piloter alors c'est la difficulté n'est
pas tellement de de de l'avion mais
plutôt de la la sensibilité de notre
société par rapport au handicap étant le
seul pilote au monde avec mon type de
handicap qui est une
arthrogripose je n'ai pas pu enfin
j'avais pas de précédent la DJS n'avait
pas de précédent il a fallu un petit peu
de temps pour les convaincre et montrer
que je pouvais évidemment piloter en
toute sécurité comme tout pilote
d'ailleurs quand je pilote je m'annonce
pas en tant que pilote handicapé je
m'once en tant que pilote pilote et la
DGAC a été très compréhensive et m'a
vraiment aidé sur le dossier mais ça a
pris quand même 4 ans h quelle est plus
généralement la place du handicap dans
dans l'aviation est-ce qu'il y a des
pilotes de ligne qui sont handicapés
alors ça c'est un rêve pour l'instant il
n'y a pas de pilote de ligne en France
il n'y a pas de pilote de ligne
handicapés ça c'est un un rêve que
j'aimerais bien concrétiser puisque dans
d'autres pays en Australie notamment il
y a des pilotes handicapés alors après
il faut être raisonnable et on peut pas
ouvrir le le le vol à n'importe quel
type de handicap il faut quand même
queon puisse voler en toute sécurité
aussi bien pour les personnes à bord que
pour les personnes au sol
et donc on est en train de travailler
avec le gouvernement et avec la ass pour
voir comment est-ce qu'on pourrait
donner accès à une à des simulateurs de
vol pour instruire les pilotes de ligne
dans un premier temps et après pourquoi
pas aller plus loin on peut peut-être
préciser juste le type de handicap dont
vous souffrez ça se caractérise par des
bras plus courts alors voilà absolument
vous êtes trèsace c'est ça c'est parce
c'est vrai qu'à l'image on le voit pas
forcément c'est pour ça handicap qui
c'est un handicap qui touche les muscles
s'appelle une arthrogripose et donc
c'est un handicap de naissance où
malheureusement mes muscles ne se sont
pas développés ou se sont mal dév
mais à force de de rééducation pendant
un certain temps 25 ans j'ai réussi à
acquérir une une autonomie qui me permet
de vivre comme vous et moi beaucoup de
volonté aussi on l'entend depuis depuis
tout à l'heure on va s'intéresser
peut-être au cas de cette pilote at de
sité exactement qu' fautussi partie de
l'association une jeune élève pilote
Manon altasin qui est sour des muettes
et vous allez le voir rien ne semble
l'arrêter quand il s'agit de voler nous
avons réalisé son portrait le samedi 27
octobre à l'aérodrome de saint-sy on
regarde ensemble ce
reportage
tout le monde est attaché tout le monde
est
attaché nouvelle journée de baptême de
l'air pour les enfants en difficultés à
l'aérodrome de saint-sir l'école
l'association fly and Kiss avait
convoqué une trentaine de jeunes
défavorisés sourds ou hospitalisés au
programme construction d'avion en bois
et vol audessus du château de Versailles
parmi la dizaine de pilotes bénévoles
présents ce jour-là Manon altasin
sourde de
naissance c'est suite à un baptême de
l'air qu'on lui avait offert quand elle
avait 16 ans que Manon altasin a décidé
de relever le défi apprendre à piloter
malgré sa
surdité voir
etre
on a l'avantage de d' avoir par rapport
au aut on a nos capacité
d'observationer par la
per très entouré dans son aéroclub des
Murau qui compte d'autres pilotes
handicapés la jeune élève est souvent
confrontée à l'incompréhension des gens
elle en a fait une motivation
supplémentaire j'ai eu des personnes qui
mais pourquoi quand tu la répétition tu
pas mais ça m'ait pe
prventé donc ça m'a P
àation c'est pas qu'on a hand aitif
moteur ch et avec comm on a une
convation par
avant aujourd'hui il existe plusieurs
aér club donc celui des Mureaux qui font
la promotion de l'aviation pour les
personnes handicapées moteur mais la loi
française interdit à un pilote handicapé
d'exercer une activité professionnelle
seul quelques-uns ont pu obtenir une
dérogation d'autres ont passé leur
licence aux États-Unis pays qui autorise
la professionnalisation des pilotes
privés handicapés Manon de son côté ne
veut pas en faire son métier son rêve de
venir
Kiner on précise donc on a sous-titré ce
reportage he à l'intention bah de toutes
les personnes sur des muettes qui qui
connaissent Manon qui pourront donc
regarder ce portrait alors une dernière
question est-ce qu'on peut espérer qu'un
jour Manon puisse voler seul parce que
là elle explique qu'elle a un copilote
hein pour utiliser la radio mais est-ce
que ce sera possible avec une nouvelle
technologie alors c'est déjà possible il
y a déjà un pilote sour qui est Henry
cordoi du tiers qui est un pilote
français qui vole en France en toute en
toute légalité et comment il fait il
vole sur des espaces non contrôlés ce
qu'on appelle des espaces non contrôlés
ce sont des espaces où la radio n'est
pas indispensable hmm bien merci à tous
les
deux fly and Kiss également sur Internet
merci Alice dans un instant à votre
place c'est une autre journaliste de la
rédaction qui va nous rejoindre Valérie
oribau ce sera pour la chronique
environnement nous sommes mardi c'est le
jour de la chronique environnement pour
le moment direction plaisir et ces
lycéens qui travaillent sur le goncours
avec l'aide de leurs
enseignants à quelques semaines de la
désignation du concours des lycéens 2012
ces élèves de première littéraire du
lycée jean-villard de plaisir se
réunissaient pour discuter et partager
leurs impressions sur les œuvres
sélection
entre peste etéra l'enfant grec ou
encore l'âme de fond ces lycéens ont
découvert un autre univers de lecture
qui parfois était un peu éloigné de leur
livre
préférés c'est pas forcément mon style
de livre c'est il y en a certains qui
m'ont pas trop plu mais d'autres qui
sont intéressants parce qu'ils sont
différents des livres de classique c'est
une bonne
aventure quelque chose d'extraordinaire
enfin h du comment ça m'aurait pas
attiré en dehors puisque c'est pas mon
style de livre que lisez-vous
classique ces lycéens avaient 11 livres
à lire en 2 mois si parfois se plonger
dans les chapitres a été difficile les
élèves se sont prêtés au jeu et leur
regard littéraire a changé les élèves
sont lancés dans la lecture là depuis le
4 septembre donc certains ont déjà tout
lu sur les 11 livres donc c'est vraiment
très très bien d'autres S sont mis un
peu plus tard mais là ça y est il
commence à y avoir une bonne dynamique
de lecture et surtout leur lecture on
mûis donc ils ont un regard beaucoup
plus aiguisé une critique beaucoup plus
fine et ça c'est vraiment
intéressant il leur reste quelques jours
pour parcourir les dernières pages des
livres pas encore ouvert un délégué de
classe se rendra à la dernière étape au
mois de novembre à Paris pour participer
à la nomination du lauréa
2012 du